because if you're white and you're
saying that you've never done that I
think you're a bit of a liar
that I've never done work I think if
you've been in a situation where you've
seen racism or you've heard something or
you haven't pulled someone up on it I
think you're alive if I saw something
racist I would say something but that's
the thing I think at some point in your
life you probably haven't and that's
what I'm trying to say why are you
making that assumption when you don't
know me why are you making certain
assumptions about me when you think I
haven't made any assumptions about you
no no no no I said I said older women
are traumatized more traumatized yeah
100 in general I never said anything
about you oh oh because I thought
earlier there was like a common uh thing
about this sounds like trauma if I said
that it sounds like trauma it was based
off of things you said I wouldn't make
it I wouldn't think I wouldn't make an
assumption about you that was not based
off of things you said yeah